Seto and welcome to this video yes
somehow that was a bit strange what my
software did the starting of this video
okay maybe test the Sicilian here with
mr. Hawke since he place the leg side
kick Roxie anyway so probably didn't
matter all that much remove order here I
go to e4 c4 I probably would have come
to the same thing yeah so this is a
well-known line in the maraca see and
it's not pretty not good for black that
has been tested in the game karwan
accountants 2015 and yeah please cosmin
are very lucky to escape with the drawn
in this game but sighs so what to do
just see take guy it's probably slide
advantage got more space and somewhat
weaker Shane you form however you always
says Bishop b2 Psalms and something that
I probably should play Bishop deform
soonish to just make this should be too
impossible forever this is a nuisance
than any ending but if I coefficient
default rate those bishops and endings
will be favorable for me as a fall will
be weak all right on the light squares
go to light squared Bishop so this is
the general plan clippership beforehand
and then then play for ending black have
some problem
here to organize it's not quite hear
what is movers be sure to the b6 square
is always covered yeah this is what I
expected actually something like this to
try to read the position okay if I take
now what how does he take with the pond
and do you want him he always has those
ideas which we should be too at the end
Bishop c4 is also move that just make
some sense I also we should be fine just
attacking those paws and well Bishop d7
cheeks I'm not sure that I want to trade
this
look do you wanna soften move I would
like to play in general don't know what
he does and if I was something i can
also take I mean it's not bad the tough
decision so need to trade dissolve d5 I
can take and go up the one that
shouldn't work so here just once to
prevent roop the one in the future but
this is perfectly okay yes yes I
attending is absolutely nice beautiful
wife look these seven is coming okay so
look c7 or the sea to England then
Bishop b5 okay
good move
I can still play Bishop b5 then and
asking about the ape on boy says
something else there a book takes takes
with the book does it want to go over to
hu maybe yeah that's possible so let's
see there should be five no I don't have
a good square to put it the point will
be dangerous from what
yeah definitely will be dangerous I need
to get my pee porn in motion as well
nice got to 55 hmm set a draw I'm not
quite sure about it I don't think I can
be worth that it would be a bit bit
strange but hmm ok one king of to a 3 B
6 55 b7 hmm it could be better than that
work Sam yeah okay so v6 is going to
move to t5 again I have to play it
should be five problem so we seven is
there any point in playing seven
probably not Jeff is simply nothing to
do here check draw offered check time
warning serious you playing this on time
Wow
let's see maybe I can get to the h1
probably not yeah but should you fall
working let probably it could be worth
for me now but we can try should still
be a draw okay check check check game
drawn ah that's a [ __ ] it's not greater
I had a pretty nice position on the
opening like this is very very
comfortable for white n terms I really
like to win those positions that are so
one-sided can maybe taking was a bishop
to be three that was sounds interesting
way to do it preventing would be one so
there the computer I mean this was not
so easy i took a bit of time here
because they all look good yeah all
those moves Bishop c4 Dearborn they all
are better for Wyatt
somewhat but it's tough to decide what
to do I wasn't I wasn't totally sure
about this movie em I want to try one
threatening actually to take because and
I let's say and the computer gives
Bishop d7 mmmm they're just for just
this this thing it isn't any good
because he always has this at the end
and that is the issue there I have a
hard time to take away any of those
weaker spawns because of the Bishop b2
counter idea this is why I took and play
specialty for to get rid of that
immediately and I mean this is probably
still bit better but I should probably
go here and not not take adds more
precise yeah I'm just activating a chain
and meiosis here and only played that
well look 28 and now i'm luke t 5 is
also better than Bishop b5 yet after
this I have may be slight pressure okay
90s closes I da MP can can still come
around teams and get the air choir which
is probably ending in about the same
thing as the game which which is very
growers okay yeah yeah simply nothing is
going on yeah i probably had chances in
this one position there to improve the
way it was it was just a little bit
guide was the true lane yeah thanks for
watching